Destiny question for you how much of
what you're doing
is
um
you're you're toying and trolling with
people where you're just kind of like a
way of getting under people's skins to
get attention and get eyeballs and then
constantly uh uh changing and evolving
where you're not letting your audience
guess who you are or put you in a box
because that is a method of building a
brand for yourself how much of it is
that versus how much of it is I'm just
changing and I'm sharing what my
opinions are today
um I'm pretty authentic I don't know if
this is true but I might have more
broadcasted content than like any other
person alive right now so like my whole
like Journey because I started I was one
I think I was the first person to quit
their job and do streaming full time in
2010
um and I've been streaming probably
seven hours a day on average for
probably the last like 12 years
um so I mean like you can see all of my
growth I don't think I could fake a
character or be like a provocateur
um for that extended period of time so
yeah there's I would I would say there's
a lot of like Natural Evolution of my
political beliefs over time got it but
like when you do uh I've seen you've
seen the thing where he's says like I
believe Joe Biden is doing a great job
or one of the greatest presidents yeah
that only sounds prove me wrong
Republican okay right exactly well Joe
Biden is doing a great job well yeah
well let's discuss that well you know
like I actually generally do believe
that you're authentic we've done an
interview before we've done a two-hour
the only thing I won't own all the time
is I can get a little wild on Twitter
okay that's fine okay being Wild on
Twitter has actually encouraged these
days okay but but I'm bringing that up
because I think uh I think a part of
what Tate does is trolling
and to get under people's skins and I
think does a great job at it I think
Jake Paul does the same thing I think
Shapiro does the same thing yeah I think
a part of what we do is the same thing
so yeah provocateur I think that's a
very appropriate word award we use today
is you know you hear the word troll more
like you saw what he did to Greta
yesterday did you guys see the back and
forth yesterday with Greta did you see
what happened with him and Greta
yesterday I'm sure you saw that okay
tayden and Greta if you want to just
click on that
So Yesterday
yeah so yesterday if you want to get
close to that so Greta says no go up a
little bit so you don't show what she
says first no no go down just read that
part yeah so Andrew Tate says hey uh
Greta I have 32 car 33 cars my Bugatti
is a 16 uh uh uh eight liter quad turbo
my two Ferrari 12 uh you know have six
and a half liter V12 this is just to
start please provide your email address
so I can send you a complete list of my
car collection and their respective
enormous emissions okay and the picture
at the bottom is the picture of him in
the Bugatti now look at what Greta does
which is actually pretty impressive how
she responds back she says please do
enlighten me email me at small Dickens
getalife.com okay and then he responds
back and it goes back and forth back and
forth and then he does a video and he
gets like 30 million views so there's a
there's a there's a model and a Madness
to this game I just wonder if that's a
part of where you're going where you're
able to to do that versus no I'm just
talk talking [ __ ] having a good time
learning
um I don't know if you can do that model
anymore so the provocateur one so here's
the issue when people talk about
trolling trolling had a distinctly
uh unique definition like 15 years ago
on the internet when you troll somebody
you're acting in a way that you know is
stupid and everybody else that knows the
troll is happening knows that it's
stupid and you do it to get a rise out
of somebody right you act like an idiot
to get a rise out of somebody the
problem is today trolling just means
like
um I don't want to say harassing
somebody but like I like insulting
somebody or attacking somebody that's
like trolling or whatever but the
beliefs are oftentimes real or even if
the people themselves don't have the
belief their fan base has it
um I would say the internet has changed
substantial over the past like 20 years
and that 15 20 years ago it was really
funny to talk about like finding people
killing them online you know saying a
bunch of crazy stuff because like
everybody knew it was a joke and it was
just a bunch of kids and we were old
guys or whatever on the internet it was
just like fun and funny
nowadays it's a lot different because
you've got people writing manifestos and
going to like Buffalo or you know
Christchurch or New Zealand and like
shooting up and killing people based on
[ __ ] they've read online so I the the
landscape has changed a lot such that
it's hard to go online and be like Oh
I'm just going to troll and say all
these things because there's probably a
sizable portion of your audience that's
going to end up unironically believing
those things
um is it Voltaire that said that like
any group that gets its laugh by
pretending to be idiots will eventually
find themselves in good company that
kind of thing no I tend to disagree with
the idea that trolls were just idiots I
think I think there are a couple
different kinds of trolls but there are
people out there who are genuinely
genuinely like disgruntled and upset
with what somebody was doing and so they
took issue with it and they became a
troll and they ended up trolling those
people and then your second point is you
know that there's been certainly there's
been a clamp down on what people are
allowed to do in terms of trolling other
people and Andrew Tate's a perfect
example they just said hey enough of
that and he was to me almost an
archetype archetypal troll like because
he just trolled the world like you know
I have 33 cars come at me whatever and
this is a great example of it so they
they might want to shut that down and
they've tried to shut him down I don't
how did he get back on Twitter like what
I mean obviously yeah but he's still not
back on Instagram and some of the other
platforms well also what about I mean
you're I think you're talking about like
changing of the landscape political
politically or ideologically like if you
look at the success that Babylon B has
had over the last hand yeah I mean
they're trolling they're trolling doing
the same thing the onion has done for
decades this took it to a whole
different level though right but so the
thing um and right now this is like I'm
autistically quibbling over definitions
so it doesn't really matter if that's
how we use troll now it's fine but like
trolling in the past would be like um
would would be like I go to a church and
I pretend to be religious and I start
like speaking in tongues that would be
like like the Borat approach to trolling
I mean that's the greatest
but the problem is with no I shouldn't
say problem um also I'm not trying to
say anything should be banned to it I'm
trying to say we need a banner server
but when people troll today they're not
actually trolling what they're doing is
extremely indicative of the underlying
belief so like the Andrew Tate stuff and
again I understand definition changeover
times we can call it trolling but there
was nothing like there wasn't much of a
joke to when Andrew was saying like a
lot of people genuinely feel like [ __ ]
off government like I want to drive my
cars same thing the reason that borout
resonated is there a lot of people who
felt the same way that he did that's why
it resonated I mean resonance is
the way something becomes popular he
became popular because it resonated he
didn't become popular because everybody
thought this guy's an idiot and so I'm
gonna watch more of his idiocy they they
thought it was funny because it
resonated with that's what humor is well
it's almost like playing a character to
expose to the idiocy of whoever and he
does a great job of trolling typically
the right I mean he'll do it to Bernie
Sanders in the left as well did you see
that the Latin this isn't Borah but this
is Sasha Baron's cone's latest Escapade
I don't know two years ago what was it
like
saving America or United States America
what was the whole thing I don't know if
you could pull it up Sasha yeah show
time he did it it was a whole thing
something about America who is America
to be like an Israeli yeah he pretended
to be an Israeli uh Mossad uh gunfighter
and he would go and basically convince
you know NRA type members that
five-year-old should be shooting guns or
he went with uh in like a boxing ring
with like a republican uh congressman
and he convinced them to like drop his
pants and like attack people with his
anus like stuff that you're like you
can't make this up he got people to do
and obviously the greatest troll he ever
did is Pat's favorite thing when he got
OJ on and pretended
that his girlfriend didn't know who OJ
was and just was like ah you remember
like like the trolling of this man is so
over the top amazing so the weird thing
is because there's a resonance with
trolls I struggle with Sasha Baron Cohen
like personally I I struggle I struggle
a lot that's funny and some of it just
makes me really uncomfortable it just
makes me uncomfortable and I don't but
that's the point right he wants to make
you uncomfortable that's true and so but
but I'm the type of person who's like
okay I don't need that I don't need that
discomfort level in my life so like that
last thing that you're talking about
that he did I didn't watch it even
though I heard funny things about it and
some of the things sounded pretty funny
yeah like overall and it's the same
thing it's like the the who are the guys
who who played all the the pranks and
did dangerous things the The Jerk Jerky
Boys Jerky Boys the best thing in the
history I know and but that to me now
she's talking about jackass she's not oh
jackass guys yeah of course yeah you're
going 80s yeah I'm going in but I think
Destiny brought up
a really good point is that whether it's
left or right Babylon B onion Borat Jack
who gives a [ __ ] I think trolls uh
making fun of people
um just joking around I think it's I
think it's I think that's part of
America I think it's humorous it's
healthy because if you can't laugh at it
of course then you're the one who has
the problem here's where I was going
with this though that's all fun and
games this is what Elon Musk kind of is
abiding by free speech I don't care if
you're left right I don't care if I'd
offend you I like all good you don't
track his chat as long as it doesn't
incite violence like you brought up
School shooters and manifestos in
Buffalo and that's I think where the
constant slippery slope is constantly
trying to be identified is like what's
trolling what's satire and what's like
no we have a problem here that we must
address and that's the problem with that
line now everybody can say some [ __ ]
which is fine but where do you draw the
line on this type of stuff I don't even
care about the like the indirect
incitement to violence that like people
call it stochastic terrorism is when
you're slowly pushing people I'm not
even necessarily worried about that like
I don't know if there should be rules or
legislation or anything I just wish that
people would be more honest like it's
never just jokes right like the jokes
are typically like they resemble some
underlying thing that people it's funny
because it's true the ruin comedy like
um for the recent like Sasha Baron Cohen
stuff that that thing you're talking
about that was funny if you were like
left-leaning and you'd like to [ __ ] on
conservatives that's why it was funny
because you got to see the ridiculous
like positions on guns and blah blah
blah blah if you watch that with a
conservative friend some of them might
not find that funny right like Sam did
well I don't know if it's because she
didn't watch it or not I didn't watch it
all right but I'm saying like some
people some conservators might not find
that funny they might be like oh well I
don't you know I'm not sure
um yeah I just don't get it I mean just
like how all conservatives don't fund
late night TV funny anymore SNL funny
because it's like but that's definitely
because you can only watch so many
[ __ ] Trump impersonations before
you're like okay let's find something
else to laugh yeah the whole thing with
comedy is misdirection a little bit and
if you already know where the joke is
going like if you watch Jimmy Kimmel and
he brings up Trump it's never going to
be like and then Trump won the lottery
and it was great it was like and Trump
just fell flat on his face and he has a
toupee sure it it that's the whole thing
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]